Violent J here from Insane Clown posi
the Duke check me out on the bootleg K
podcast all right we rolling man bootleg
C podcast special guest here one half of
Ip uh hip-hop
Legend uh this guy has uh yo man this
violent Jay is here from inan clown posy
man it's good to see you brother it's
good to see you my man and I want you
know I appreciate being here man I've
been I dm'd you a while ago and I'm glad
that you like we finally made this
happen cuz ICP for whatever reason was
just like an intrical part of my
childhood and I never was like a big fan
of you guys I was always like it was
just around me yeah like I never was in
your guys' music I'll say it wasn't like
I was like it's an acquired taste 100% I
remember my cousin Zach moved from Texas
to Arizona when I was probably like 10
and all he was listening to was the
great malinko and so that album I I like
I you guys had great skits and yeah you
know it was like real we got that from
Ice Cube you know yeah yeah you guys had
some ill skits um and then I just like I
got to give you guys flowers cuz I do
feel like you guys kick the door down
for so much of the
entrepreneurialship that I don't you
know I don't know if people ever give
you credit or not but you know whether
it's the merch the throwing your guys'
own Festival like you guys been doing
Gathering of the Jugos how many years
it's going to be the uh 29th next year
almost 30 years yeah and so like
nowadays we'll see artists like Tyler
the Creator do his own festival and like
all but like I'm like you guys have been
doing it for so long man we've been
doing this yeah yeah man and uh this
year Halloween is our 30th annual in
Detroit we we play Halloween every year
in
Detroit called Hall Wicked clown show
yeah and uh this is our 30th year that's
crazy 30 years damn yeah man I'm 36 [__]
yeah man I'm 50 I'm 51 in this but I got
to tell you something yeah I got to tell
you something this is real [__] yeah if
I have known when I was in my
20s that at
51 my conversation
with and the way it is with my boys
would be this dope I wouldn't have
worried about getting old I thought I'd
be corny as you know what I'm saying I
thought I'd be like my Tom just standing
there like everything he says is corny
as you know what I mean and and I
thought I'd be like him you know what
I'm saying but it my conversations are
the same as when I was in my 20s and
you're touring and you're still putting
out new albums oh all the time yeah but
you know what I mean like it's not as
bad as you thought plus the other thing
is when you know how kids they don't
look at you they're just old school
whatever you you know when you get older
you get wisdom yeah so that don't offend
you and you're also not afraid I mean
you're also not interested in what
they're doing because your generation is
getting older too so my heroes Snoop and
everybody you know what I'm saying
they're all here you know like they're
all our age so we're still watching each
other and the game continues yeah for
sure but when you start off young you
think that's the only game there is is
what's happening on the hottest the
hottest [__] bumping off but man when
you know tell that to Madonna she's
still killing it in her world you know
what I'm saying dropping albums and well
I mean look hip-hop's the newest uh I
mean one of the newest genres right it
just turned 50 it actually we were
finally seeing the ogs become like real
ogs and like and and the other thing is
being 51 bro I saw the beginning of
hip-hop right yeah and that's a blessing
bro I saw the beginning of hip-hop I
lived on this Earth with Michael Jackson
Prince you know what I'm saying those
guys will hopefully become iconic for
hundreds of years right you you know
it's an honor to be up here and be able
to you know that type yeah man it's cool
though but like do you do you feel like
you guys get the credit for some of the
business because I feel like you guys
set up some business models that other
artists like I I you know I've told this
to Tech 9 Tex my brother love Tech but I
feel like Tech and strange get credit
for a lot of the that y'all were doing
like years prior you know what I mean
like I discovered Tech through you guys
you know what I'm saying yeah yeah man
we and Tech man we almost we almost went
to war you know what I'm saying right
because it it got um it was 2017 you
know what I'm saying and that was a a
pivotal year in the Jugo lore because
the number 17 is is is everything that's
the only calendar year with 17 in it in
all our in the Jugo lives you know so
anyway that year we were uh also suing
the FBI because they put us on the gang
they put jug as a gang you know so we're
doing a March on Washington and all this
right and
um Tech goes on Hot
97 and he's telling stories about
fictitious basically rumor he's talking
about like a a raw dog line at the
Gathering you know like 15 ninjas gang
banging a chick or whatever that sh
ain't you know what I'm saying it's it
that ain't true you know what I mean
I've heard I've heard of some of the
weird [__] that's at the the Gathering
that's pretty Gnar I'm just saying no no
no I'm not mad about tech no more but
the way he put it down it wasn't it
wasn't it wasn't it wasn't our our what
we were doing you know so it wasn't
helping what you guys had going on at
that time exactly right and the other
thing was we were doing a concert there
we played uh Rudy where did we play
right at the Lincoln Memorial yeah right
and um it was a free concert right and I
during the march we did we marched on
Washington there like thousands of
jugglers out there we did a March cuz
this is we we don't know how else
to they said they're a gang it was
insane you you guys had by 2017 you were
on the gang list for years by that point
right yeah since 11 since it happened in
2011 but here's the thing you got to
understand bro when in certain parts of
the country when people are on a gang
list like if a Jugo gets pulled over and
he he suddenly on a gang list you know
what I'm saying it's a problem he might
be having a custody battle for his kids
right and his wife his ex-wife attorney
like this is a gang member according to
the government United States something
according to the government in the
United States you know what I mean like
this was [__] up uh dude was a
probation officer for 15 years right
when that gang resonate thing came out
uh when we made the top 10 gangs she got
fired I mean right in the pink slip it
was like we saw it on your Facebook you
know what I mean you're out of here you
know what I mean like wow so in a lot of
people's lives people were getting
thrown out of the military bro I always
tell people told to uh um cover their t
tattoos or have removed I say this all
the time I say there are real teachers
teaching our kids right now with hatch
man tattoos in America but anyway the
point was um with the tech tech had so
so many jug fans right tons yeah you
guys Shar so many fans he should have
played that concert you get what I'm
saying so I asked him I felt like it was
way in advance you know what I mean but
I asked them play the concert like come
do this man we're paying back we're
going through this they're putting this
on jugal you know what I mean really
lives up we don't know how else to
combat it by except doing this marching
concert you know and uh we tried suing
them and four times it got thrown out of
court to in the FBI yeah yeah you know
what I'm saying so um cuz it you talked
about merchandise and expensers and Hot
Topics guess when that ended when 201
2011 the second that gang year was like
[__] out of here all that it totally
that [__] up you know what I mean and
it's like we're just chilling here
Independent Business artists you know
what I'm saying what the [__] is a
problem you know what I mean like what
is any it's so outrageous yet we just
lost yeah you know saying so are you
guys still on that list the list don't
exist no more it came out in 2011 yeah
right that was the only year they ever
announced a list like that right you
know what I'm saying so you guys are on
that list with like the Crips the Bloods
probably Hell's Angel Nation
ms3 jug crazy you know what I'm saying
did you ever get an ex explanation why
let me tell you something bro there was
a book that came out right called jug
and um we had nothing to do with this
book Right This Mother book there are X
jug I guess or sellout jug right whose
career it is or was I don't know to
travel around to police departments and
give a seminar on Jugo identification
showing them all the labels in in
crazy you know what I'm saying read this
know so many jungalow and they're very
very harmless people they're the most
[__] wonderful people like what what the
they're hardworking American citizens
like I don't understand what the [__]
the thing is you know so what they come
from broken homes you know what the like
what can they do about it you know what
I'm saying like they're they're I don't
know what like I don't know what makes
them any less important of anybody else
people always say oh the only one into
this [__] Are The Jug you know what the
are jug right people just
yeah just because they have a name it's
like the only one having fun only one
liking ICB is people I just met a guy I
met a guy recently like last week
actually uh my boy who's I won't even
say who he is because you guys might
know him you guys definitely know the
rapper but his his guy who's on the road
with him had a I mean he's just fully
tattooed with like Twisted you guys like
he's [__] and I was like oh you're a
jugal he's like I'm a recovering jugal
bro and I was like never heard that
interesting what does that mean I don't
know he's got all the tattoos he's just
a joke or
something I don't know what covering jug
is I just was covering so if you yeah
well I want to put a B on the tech thing
cuz you guys are fine now I get it now
he's dissing us he's saying like I used
to be into that [__] but I'm I'm off
that [__] now whatever oh okay so was
the last time you guys talked who you
and Tech um well man we let me tell you
something then he put out in his song He
said my name in a song you know what I'm
saying and he's talking about Joe Bruce
and um I don't remember how I word it
but it sounded like a [__] disc right
so it it's getting really heated up you
know and
um he we talked he I had to [__]
drive to a gas station and I just get
was in my car you know what I'm saying
I'm a taxer he want he want to get on
the pH guy yeah so I'm like all right
here we go you know three hours bro I
respect the let me say this I respect
the [__] [__] out of that man
he's the best hands down man that
[__] is a real one for sure okay
he talked sense into me he's one of the
realest dudes in the game I always say
that man and he's a humble guy he was
like um
brother you don't want jugal to be
labeled as a gang if me and you fall out
that's exactly what they're going to be
you know what I mean
because you know he was telling me he's
he's he's with the blood he's a blood
and if we go to war you know what I'm
saying it's going to be jug against
Bloods and [__] and I just was like The
Jug are fan base you know what I'm
saying and also they're not out here
like that well this is the thing if you
go to a tech show but they are though
bro Unfortunately they are like that
Tech was like man these got
[__] waiting in line at at meet
and greet coming up and trying to swing
on and [__] like I she [__] you know
he's telling these stories to me and
he's like he's he he uh one of his shows
got the bomb threat or whatever we
hadn't even fallen out right you know
what I mean what what is the website we
hadn't even Fallen you guys have a
pretty dedicated internet fan base
what's it fol lovers. net they've
covered some of my interviews is it fol
lovers at the lovers yeah I think so
yeah I I don't know if there's if that's
a website right right but they but I
know that they'll like speculate on [__]
you know yeah I don't go there right I
don't [__] with him anymore I used to
like him but uh I don't [__] with I
don't go there no more I don't you know
I don't really go on any websites like
that but but but you guys have that
three-hour conversation and everything
yeah it was intense bro he was like look
man you know I he was like I'm telling
you right now um what was he saying and
I was like do you think I'm afraid of
you like he was like you do not want to
um he said you do not want to go to war
man man we we don't want to go to war
over this and I'm like exactly and um he
said something but I was like do you
think I'm soft bro do you think that's
I'm afraid of that to war with you and
he said I am you know what I mean
somehow he put it like he was like I'm
afraid bro we don't need to be doing
this you know what I mean and it was I
don't remember exactly it was 5 years
ago but yeah it we worked it out man
beauti thank God and we worked it out
and that oh and he also put me up on
game about who his whole thing because I
I was like bro you know you start
wearing a paint I didn't never seen him
wear the paint until halfway through the
wick and woner tour right you know what
I'm saying not halfway through maybe
like beginning of it but I know I he
wasn't wearing a paint at the beginning
you know so I thought okay he's he's
he's doing what we're doing that's cool
you know what I'm saying so then it's
now it's a thing he still does you know
but he was telling me man I've been
wearing paint since way before you you
know what I'm saying and not before for
me but you get what I'm saying since way
before he always kind of went by like
the Killer Clown you know back in the
day exactly you know seen him in no pain
yeah yeah well he was though you know he
he he was um pictures and [__] yeah he
put me up on game he told me about his
history and everything and
um it always seemed like you guys had
such a like a shared fan base like if
you go to a tech show I've been like
probably 50 Tech shows in my life hey
you're always going to see jug there
every time he was like my security
thinks my security tells me um he said
my security uh says we should just we
should uh what did he say my security
says he wants to kick you some [__] like
that right and I was like [__] that dude
you know [__] him for thinking that you
know whatever his appointment whatever
the thing was anyway so then Tech comes
to Detroit on tour at State Theater and
um and I'm
like you know this is all happening
right so anyway we worked it out where
uh me and Joey are gonna go up on stage
and introduce them you know what I'm
saying that's dope yeah so so we went up
there and introduced them on stage you
know but when I got to the venue right
the [__] security [__] throws me
against the wall you know what I'm
saying my OG mugs yeah man like and I'm
like what the [__] y'all you know what
I'm saying like get off me he didn't
know what was happening probably
right okay okay they just did he was
telling me okay okay okay his security
was like [__] them dudes you know and I
was like well [__] them tell them [__]
you you know what I mean so when I got
there they were rough you know even
though I'm there to make the [__]
peace you know what's crazy is the last
time I saw Tech was last year we were in
Detroit when I told you and he happened
to have a show across the street from
where the Tigers play right by the
Eminem uh restaurant yeah yeah yeah
that's right where I'm talking about
yeah yeah so we went to the show and I I
told I told people like uh you know I'm
from Arizona so we have a certain type
of white trash is it's we have our own
specific white trash you know but at
that show being in the crowd at a tech
show in Detroit I got to see
Detroit white trash and I was like oh I
got I got it like I got it I was like oh
I get it now like this is like you know
Auto Factory like you know middle of
America Rust Belt [__] is different
you know what I'm
saying fans are white trash no no I'm
saying that I I'm saying that there's I
mean I I'm white trash
I'm not saying that I I definitely got
to see some white trash at the tech 9
show not all of them were white trash
what is what is you know but it was just
it was just funny cuz I was just like
you know we have our own type of white
trash like my family is like bunch of
meth heads and like you know biker dudes
right that's like Phoenix white TR that
everybody white though that's fair you
know I'm
say I was just say the Detroit white
trash was definitely hitting different I
got it I was like yo this might have
been Eminem if he didn't make it like
standing here watching Tech 9 like you
know what I'm saying yeah man but man
yeah he's the [__] man I really Tech's
great man I'm glad you guys worked that
out I didn't I knew you I knew that
there was some sort of like um like it
was out there that you guys had it might
have been an issue but I you know I knew
it was squashed I just didn't know the
back story how that
happen if we were going to go to war
like that we going to come at him hard
of course you know what I mean because
he's so in our integrated in our world
world yeah I'm saying so we weren't just
going to you know but no of course yeah
but time I saw him was on the wicked
walking uh the wicked Wonka tour at Mesa
Amphitheater it was what was that you
guys Bone Thugs Cotton Mouth Kings and
Tech yeah and
uh and E I wasn't on there Tech after
that's you didn't do none of the dates
you were on the [__] Halloween song
with us we all did a song together
too I that and what's crazy is that that
tour for like that period of time Cotton
Mouth Kings were [__] huge oh yeah
they had their own is that an
unfortunate thing with them man I know
that they I know well I know that they
had like a falling out like certain
members I think dadd we tried to bring
them together cuz they were another huge
Staple in the war Sr you what I mean
yeah no for sure rest in peace
[__] you can't even get two of
them together yeah they all hate each
other it's insane like like we we did a
me me and Joey me and Shaggy did a whole
[__] uh episode of our podcast trying
to uncover what really happened you know
what I'm saying I heard certain [__] cuz
I I think it was like a initially like a
split and then the uh what's the dude's
name who owns Suburban noise uh [__] I
can't think of his name right now what's
the guy's name who owns oh oh [__] yeah
um I know his name too what the [__]
Kevin Zinger Kevin kining Zinger yeah
all right U um but bro here's the thing
why it's so unfortunate okay okay
look ICP mhm right right I ain't NE me
and Shaggy ain't never made the money
we're making right now ever so you guys
at this moment are making the most money
you've ever made [__] yes when we had
four albums on the chart bro listen what
I'm saying it's Nostalgia mhm okay when
we had four um albums on it on a charts
you know what I'm saying and you guys
were 1,000% going Platinum yeah in in
the '90s yeah we we figured it out we
sold 8 million records crazy and I don't
know nothing about that's when records
were here right right right that's when
go to the store it's been a few years
since streams have been around I don't
know how to [__] do that but I know
one of our singles Hocus Pocus just went
gold in stream how many years later yeah
just in streams just in streams on its
own you know like like in in because of
the Tik Tok [__] you know what I'm
saying they did like a um like a thing
to it um Hocus Pocus and they you know
they got these fanss they do you know
what I'm saying it was called clown
check I think you know anyway that [__]
went gold cuz the Tik Tok were like a
yeah congrats yeah I mean but anyway
what I was going to say the reona point
of this is this Nostalgia man for these
old groups like like okay like let me
tell you my my boy Vin ice when he came
out right look at how [__] massive
right right Ben this my Rec was hurting
right you get what I'm saying he was
opening for us and and like
he was hurting though you get what I'm
saying like he wasn't he was just
playing Rock clubs he he was you know
what I'm saying I remember he yeah I
remember small venues you get what I'm
saying years go by look at them now you
know what I'm saying on the I love the
'90s tour right all of those [__]
acts had to hurt for a minute yeah it's
dope to see tone L salt pepper [__]
uh no that's a sick tour to see like
that like that and that Torell like even
like Bone Thugs as well Bone Thugs
killing Bone Thugs used to [__] play the
small venues yeah shots are crazy like
like you know like us our whole icp's
entire career we play like 2,000 seat
venues except for the wicked Wonka tour
yeah because we had all the
mother you guys did
like yeah about 2,000 yeah no I've been
you know what I'm saying so
um um but look at the look at the
Nostalgia though you know what I'm
saying like it's different now you get
what I'm saying like um okay like let me
give you an example um I I give this
example a lot and if anybody's watching
and they hear me say this a lot I'm
sorry but Vanilla Ice [__] um we used
to play festivals in in the 90s in early
2000s right every once in a while we get
booked on a festival there'd be like 500
to a th000 jugal up front the rest of
the crowd literally bro would be like
you know yeah it was kind of cool to
hate you guys it was cool to hate you
guys for a while yeah what everybody's
like [__] you they're here to see system
of a town they're here to see cyers Hill
they're like [__] Y'all you know that
was always a our whole experience we
stopped doing [__] festivals for 20
years because our own [__] yeah we're
like [__] [__] we're going to do our own
we do our own thing and we're jugged out
right we're doing our thing and and we
got out we're signing bands we're doing
our thing all in our own little jug
world or whatever right and
um [__] Vanilla Ice in 2017 is like
yo I want you to come out and do do a
song you know what I mean and I'm like
what where are you playing I'm thinking
he's going to save your shelter you know
he's like I'm at um I'm at Pine Knob you
know I'm like this [__] Amphitheater
I'm like what's going on he's like I
love the '90s tour this is five years
ago bro he's out there he's been doing
he's still doing I remember that tour
yeah it's still it's still going I feel
like every year it is that's what I'm
saying it's massive they do multiple
tours at once you know what I'm saying
so um these guys were hurting bro they
were playing [__] small rock clubs
300 people and look at them now yeah you
know and anyway the point was he he
called us out and [__] the place
exploded and me and Joy are like we tell
them before we're not used to this yeah
we're like no we told them before we're
like you don't want to bring us out bro
because that cuz you're used to if the
crowd's not there to see you guys
they're not I thought everybody's going
to boo and he was going to be like what
the [__] you know what I mean and I when
I heard a show I'm like bro you don't
want to bring us out there you know
especially on the iso the90s to
allthough that we were the exact
opposite right of that [__] we were the
wicked [__] you know what I mean we were
like [__] the radio andu right right
right right right right you know and I'm
like why you want to bring us out there
and he's like come on man and so when
when um me and Shaggy came to the front
and they put us on the [__] screens
the whole [__] place exploded and we
were like
what that's crazy you know what I'm
saying we hadn't done a festival in 20
years bro nothing like that just your
own [__] just our own [__] the biggest
PR we do every year is the Gathering or
holwick in front of those are like our
staple events you know but man we
thought uh you know even when we walked
the Red Carpet One Time in in early
[__] 2000s at the Billboard Awards
right they had bleachers and fans all in
the bleachers me and Shaggy got out of
the limo they [__] pooed and we were
like [__] Y what are we doing here we
yelling we don't go to a war shows or MV
[__] we were like what are we doing here
[__]
y on the red carpet with the back street
Bo right right right right I never saw
none of those photos either how the [__]
could those photos not show up we were
chilling with the back street boys you
guys were with the that's [__] crazy
that makes no sense it's like a dream
where did those pictures go they didn't
have phones like this back then they
didn't have phones no this is a red car
carpet I know but it was there somewhere
yeah man that's crazy weird no so um
let's talk about the Gathering because
it is a it is a thing did you ever see
the Workaholics episode about that [__]
was hilarious yeah it was they did it
good too yeah it was good man there's a
movie that came out called family mhm
and the character in the movie is a jug
right and she goes to the Gathering and
they asked us to uh a cameo and be like
we're on stage at man me me and uh shagy
are like what is this going to be you
little Ricky D [__] they rebuilt the
[__] Gathering you show up and you're
like oh [__] there was a rides right
carnival rides you know a crowd right
you know what I'm saying tents
everywhere people on golf carts partying
and [__] bonfires I'm like how the [__]
did they do that you know what I mean it
was crazy and um yeah it was cool man
you guys uh so I've had I've had lots of
friends perform I was trying to [__] the
chick from uh uh oranges the new what is
it Orange is the New Black yeah [__]
yeah she's in that movie yeah I was me
and her dog we were [__] spit she
knows it she knows it yeah we were
spitting gang and and the other chick
was there from um um
[__] family pie American Pie American
Pie Pie she was there and um she knew it
too yeah you know what I mean and she
was she kept going like you know we were
just spitting game like talking like we
weren you know anyway then um we talked
on text for like a month and then it
ended but we didn't K I didn't mean we
spitting game like yeah like we were
talking about [__] interesting [__] you
know what I mean I wasn't like I'mma get
in your panties and [__] [__] like hey
you got a mirror in your pants cuz I can
see myself in there you know mean but it
was dope no I was going to ask you so
I've heard some okay so I heard at the
Gathering there's some crazy [__] going
on I've seen video of the feet guy have
you seen this guy he's like the guy at
the Gathering who like licks all the
chicks feet no man I ain't seen that
thank I've heard about the drug bridge
at a certain point in time wasn't there
a drug a bridge where like it was kind
of I wish there was still a drug brid
should be it was like a nice like safe
open like everybody can go and have go
there and get your [__] I don't know man
I just don't want nobody to um you know
get hurt and die of course of course of
course well this was before I think we
had to worry about like Fentanyl and
[__] this was obviously years ago you
know yeah exactly yeah yeah and and then
and then um our good allegedly that's
why I said ised allegedly these things
didn't happen all this was not a thing
we
did thing here's where we put it's like
on the it's not like on the festival map
there was like drug Bridge like it was
just like it was like a fan thing it's
in the program
no and then um yo jelly roll told told
me about some sort of [__] tent or
something that was going on allegedly
there was a [__] tent that's dope what's
wrong with that nothing's wrong with
that there should be some in several
locations that we would look just wait a
minute consent adults wait a minute I'm
sorry yeah that's actually a [__]
great idea a [__] tent what the [__] we
can provide like six tents on the ground
big red tents and light them up all red
right yeah and be like and you go in
there and it's just all lavish and clean
a place you go in there [__] you know
you're all in a wet tent you know what
I'm saying mosquitoes and [__] you boys
are right outside the nylon you know
what I mean you can go away to the [__]
tent you know what I'm saying you guys
for a small fee oh yeah like like a
little and then there's just like you
know willing lovelies in there you know
cuz all we're getting is a tent
consenting willing allegedly allegedly
consenting jugetes I don't know what
that's actually dope like that's
actually a dope idea [__] not a terrible
idea what's the craziest thing is it
really it's a bad idea no it's not a bad
idea what's the craziest thing with your
own eyes you've seen at the uh at at the
Gathering that you can talk about
allegedly that you allegedly saw with
your own eyes no man I I allegedly
nothing to Gathering is off the [__]
chain I dude I want to I want to [__]
go what's in the middle of Ohio right
bro listen I I I I really advise you to
go on account of this I know you're a
wise man MH and there's nothing worth
more than experiences memories for sure
you know what I'm saying and you will
absolutely never forget not if you live
to be a thousand right going to the
Gathering bro and and there is
absolutely no [__] danger right
that's the biggest misconception didn't
didn't somebody get booed off stage it
was was it Tila Tequila yeah that I saw
and then didn't who is unless you're an
artist unless you're an artist and they
don't like you cuz wow what a weird
thing I just said there's no danger then
you're like what about t unless you're
an artist absolutely right there has
been rappers that they've thrown [__] at
[__] yeah my heroes bro i' I've seen man
I've seen some of my heroes go down and
leave the stage you know what I mean wow
like who Too Short oh they almost got
Old Dirty Bastard off oh and it was I
believe the last concert of his life wow
oh you had obb at the Gathering right
before he passed away yeah that's crazy
were you able to talk with him when he
got there who was up there somebody ran
up there with ODB that sounds and was
like cuz they were throwing [__] and ODB
was starting to get mad you know I I
mean they throw [__] that's what they do
they're not always trying to hit you
right they're just throwing [__] look at
in the air they throw [__] there's just
[__] flying everywh
including at the stage you know and some
people don't know how to do it other
people like yellow wolf that
[__] caught you know and drank
it in the place popped you [__] Stone
Cold catching a beer on the [__]
exactly the crowd loved it like he's
he's saying I got no problem with this
yeah I'm rocking this you know what I
mean and and um that's what you the kind
of energy you have to have cuz sometimes
guys get up there and they get they want
a thug you know and that is of course
the worst think CU if you th on one
Jugo Gathering of the good jug
everyone's turning against you're in the
wrong place you know what I'm saying
yeah no as as that's crazy I didn't know
you guys had or even if you're up there
trying to act like you're too harder
than them right right right right right
and you know what I'm saying the only
ones that ever got away with clearly
looking harder than them was [__] um
last
year who played last year the the main
group
group um I can't remember I'm getting so
dumb um not suicide boys the other um um
those dudes I know you're talking about
um city morg city morg yeah city morg
city Mor goes up there bro they killed
it they killed it [__] slay them wow
like I that's they love that Wicked [__]
city morg is is a a version of wicked
[__] and suicide boys listen to them
they do that 36 mafia [__] yeah it's
like very [__] 3 SE suicide boys are
very very 36 mafia style man I feel like
DJ Paul's kind of adopted the Jugo SL
American fanas pretty heavily me and DJ
Paul are actually [__] very close no
he's a great guy he's so [__] great
man you know what I'm saying we did an
album together he wouldn't stay at my
house I have my studios in in my front
yard right right he wouldn't stay at my
house because he didn't like the woods I
live and he's like [__]
that I'm like what what do you think a
bear is going to jump through the window
or something that's crazy but he's the
[__] man he's so dope I love him man yo
so when you guys got put on that list
did you notice besides getting taken out
of stores besides all of the financial
ramifications that happened were you
guys like being followed by the police
ever cuz you I don't know we like you
guys didn't never have any sort of like
idea like man these [__] are
like making like our lives very hard
like cuz you know if if you're obviously
you guys are you know what's crazy
though man the um ACL what is it the
ACLU yeah they [__] jumped on our
side fire yeah shout to them jumped on
our side and and they were in the court
with us and [__] wow straight up that's
[__] sick yeah we did a press press
conference and everything you know what
I mean amazing man it was insane man and
we um so we we uh we did the [__]
March right
um and
uh um it's a publicity stunt right
that's what it is so we did this press
run and and man me and Shaggy were run
some crazy [__] you know out in New York
like talking about it and it sounds like
we're it sounds so [__] outrageous it
cuz it but we did like all the [__] in
New York all the shows right and I feel
like we succeeded MH like I don't like
you said at the beginning you said you
don't think jugal um get their due
respect I feel like y'all don't get your
respect for I feel like your guys'
business models you guys were the first
to really be fully vertical yeah like
you guys were able to like do your own
merch throw wrestling shows have your
own Festival like these are things
things that like first of all like
everybody's doing nowadays you know what
I'm saying
um rap trivia for anybody out there
listening I'm going to name four labels
okay
um let's see Luke records MH rapalot
records Death Jam
records Death Row Records andan clown
posi was signed to one
does anybody know that was it Death Jam
yes yeah it was Death Jam yeah we were
on Death
Jam how ridiculous does that sound now
me it's just like I remember [__] Leo
Cohen was it was was uh screaming in my
face oh my God tell me about that bro
like a thug I can't imagine Leo Cohen
getting you
guys I don't think he did but I remember
we we we were supposed to do these
Branch visits when we're on tour we go
in we're in the New Jersey Branch for
the label and we meet everybody you know
and um we were skipping that [__] you
know what I'm saying we just didn't want
to keep doing that we're tired and [__]
you know so we're just not anyway we got
to New York man and he [__] he was
like you think you're from the street
I'm from the [__]
Street you know what I'm saying and it
was just like you know and then he was
like now let's get to business he was
like I get you anybody he was all sudden
was cool as [__] he's like we can get
anybody you [__] want on a record on
a record right you name it it's
happening you know what I mean and it
went from I thought I'm about to fight
this dude right to now I want to [__]
the dude I was pause uh I was going to
say who who ended up bringing you guys
into the label like who was the no what
happened was we were on island island
and then and then Island merged right
okay merg and then Island was gone ah
yeah yeah you know what I'm saying so
they kind of inherited you guys I
remember walking through the office at
Death Jam right and people are like what
is this Halloween the whole label cuz
they had no idea they yet was just like
what the [__] is this and um here's the
funny thing
right we sold 2 million albums for
[__] Island right right our next our
next album is platinum right um we do we
do a double album and they both almost
go gold
right
now they just de Jam let they just let
the contract expire we didn't get
dropped well you guys did that they
didn't resign I remember you guys
dropped two albums on the same day right
yeah that's what I'm saying you guys did
that before Nelly huh no cuz it was two
different albums you had to buy both
yeah exactly you guys did that before
Nelly cuz Nelly did it but like y'all
really I think you guys are the first
people to be like oh man we did it we do
we did it cuz he did it oh the Judgment
Day album you know what I'm saying he
did night and day and back in the day
and just clocked on everybody you know
it's like yeah cuz your fans are going
to just buy one [__] yeah they're going
to buy two and why would you combine
them yeah [__] that you know but um yeah
we here we are you know what I'm saying
and they just let our contract expire
yeah so suddenly we signed with another
label for [__] million dollars wow
who's at the label the label was a new a
new label okay right right and they were
called um D3 D3 D3 entertainment D3 is
um they had Old Dirty Bastard they had
us they they uh was that Quincy Jones
son maybe I'm tripping that's qd3 qd3
that's what I'm thinking yeah yeah yeah
yeah okay okay but um man it just was
insane because they that gy could
have like sold us to another label if
they didn't want us right you know what
I'm saying or got some override you know
what I mean like here you guys can have
but we're getting points you know we
yeah they let us walk you know what I
mean probably better for you they didn't
even I don't think they even knew our
attorney was like yo it's two weeks Def
Jam hasn't resigned yet you know and
then he's like yo it's a week you know
and then he's like they didn't resign
right and he's like um don't say nothing
uh he's like don't say anything we'll
let a week pass and then we'll notify
him that we're leaving we're leaving
we're gone you know what I mean not that
we wanted to leave it's just that we
yeah they just became everything Chang
can you um I feel like you guys did such
a great job of branding cuz I remember
all like like there was like the series
of albums where all of the covers were
very similar then you'd open the book
and the CDs were all very Sim like you
guys had like very dope branding like
every album had a different clown and
then the Jersey would go with it or the
shirt who cuz I I do feel like um you
know on the marketing side you guys were
amazing who was kind of the brainchild
behind like some of the early like [__]
that you guys would come up with May
whether it be like hey we got to make
sure this line of albums are consistent
with the art and the CDs and they all
kind of go together I Know This Much
doing that [__] back then um is the
reason we still move physical units
today yeah you know what I'm saying
people it's their collector's yeah it's
like people people always are going to
wonder what you're going to do you know
like we'll put like a [__] pair of 3D
glasses in there and and put all kind of
crazy [__] in there and we put a booklet
with like mazes and funny I remember
that I remember yeah you guys had the
mazes on the front yeah yeah and then
like you could pull [__] out and make a
piece of dice and you know what I mean
it's just cool like uh you know what I'm
saying but yeah we we include we do [__]
like that and try to do really good
packaging and um to our benefit that
comes from back in the day though any
you know I don't know I don't know where
that comes from we are that's just
always done it like that you know you
guys just always kind of had a knack for
like I think so yeah that's the best way
of putting it can you give me the
origins of the hatchet man logo yeah man
that everyone has tattooed in the very
beginning me and Joey me and Shaggy he's
like um we had two we had two ideas for
the label name one was one was a great
name mad paper boy right and and it was
going to be a guy on a bike with a with
a um a [__] newspaper like like like
the game and to call it back then this
is before paper was known as money
though because um there was a [__]
paper boy used to come through looking
like [__] Napoleon Dynamite kind of
right and and [__] throwing papers
everywhere and um he was our boy we just
loveed to see him so we were like how
about mad paper uh records and um I
thought that would have been cool the
other one was Psychopathic you know it's
same idea but now it's just a guy with a
instead of a paper he's got the uh the
um hatchet man you know what I mean yo
we got to stop the interview again and
tell you about our folks at odd Soxs
baby that's right shout out to odd Soxs
man the most comfortable socks in the
world they've been riding with us since
day one um and let me tell you something
man Christmas time is is really sneaking
up um odd Soxs official.com use the
promo code bootleg save 20% off at
checkout they got the crazy licenses
check out these Naruto socks [__]
fire little SpongeBob socks you know
what I'm saying how about this how about
the how high movie socks they got the
WWE they got the [__] Cheetos
socks you know what I'm saying shout out
to the [__] Cheetos socks they
just dropped their Monopoly line too I'm
waiting for them to send them to me Ahad
send me the Monopoly [__] buddy all
right also the odd Soxs Basics these are
my favorites they're just normal just
you know the most comfortable socks
you've ever put on your feet is really
what they are get them black white red
[__] tie-dye whatever you're into and
they got the underwear baby L Reese's
boys let's go odd box official.com use
the promo code bootleg they got South
Park underwear too all the licenses WWE
scarf phas Breaking Bad South Park Power
Rangers Monopoly cocacola they got it
all use that promo code bootleg and save
20% off at checkout also want to give a
shout out to our sponsor uh much love to
our good Folks at bluechew that's right
we talk about it all the time on the
podcast when you go to blue.com right
now you can get your first month for
free a lot of people ask well what is
blue and does it work well blue sh it
has the same active ingredient as Viagra
and Calis the only difference is you
don't have to go to the doctor it's all
online you go to blu.com you get your
[__] handled over there and then they
get you handled by sending you a month
for free when you use the promo code
bootleg blu.com promo code bootleg try
out blue Chu it'll have your uh your
dick harder than it's ever been it's
like trigonometry in high school real
hard
you know if you're dealing with any sort
of erectile
dysfunction uh blue will have your right
like I said same active ingredient as
viagran Calis minus the awkward doctor's
appointment everything's online and if
you're asking well I don't know man I
just don't know try it out for free for
a month they'll send you a month supply
for free right to your doorstep in
discret packaging blue chewable form
it's in a little it's a little chewable
man you take that thing down and then
you go to Pound Town take your shorty to
Pound Town godamn it blue.com use promo
code bootleg try for free for a month
let's get back to the interview it's
crazy because I mean thousands upon
thousands of people have tattoos of you
guys do you remember the year that you
first noticed like cuz that's got when
artists get like have fans that are that
dedicated it's I I can only imagine how
trippy it's got to be when it first
happens be like yo this guy's got us
tattooed on him like do you remember
like when you guys first started to
notice that you guys' fans were that
dedicated cuz that's a level of
commitment that man what what what do
you say to a ninja that walks up to you
pulls his shirt off and his entire back
you know is all [__] in his whole
body sometimes you know what I mean what
do you say right how do you even react
to that that's just something it it it
it's like the type of person I am I it
makes me uncomfortable a ping of um a
ping of uh heart you know what I mean or
whatever the [__] term is because I
don't know how the [__] to you know
respond to that it's so stunning are you
are you used to it yet cuz at this point
we're talking I'm not I'll never be used
to that and I'll never understand it you
know um I don't want to say the wrong
thing I love the the [__] devotion
and dedication you get what I'm saying
but me I I you know I I I would um one
thing I don't like doing I'm not I don't
like signing my name for an autograph
because they get because they'll get a
tattooed on a hottie right I don't want
that I'm like man if you were my woman I
don't want that ninja's name yeah like I
don't want to I don't want to I don't
want to ruin your love life 5 years from
now I'm like no I don't I'm not used
especially I'm you know I'm not going to
do it to any I don't like that you know
what I'm saying we sign it try I get a
tattoo [__] no you you know but uh if if
some if a dude wants that whatever man I
just I just don't give a [__] myself I
don't give a [__] about an autograph
right I don't have no autograph I don't
have any pictures of any me and anybody
I don't give a [__] you know what I mean
n yeah I can imagine bro cuz the only
person that ever um the only person that
ever made me and uh Shaggy nervous to me
was when we met Vince McMahon hey that
had to be sick Bro our [__] mouths
dried out like we were both like and he
was like hey who who won the Grim Tim
contest you know and that was like a
contest we were having back then you
know and we just looked at well I
remember you guys coming out um I mean
you guys are for people I mean I'm a
huge wrestling fan and you guys are also
very heavily uh aligned in the wrestling
world you guys have had your own uh the
jugal wrest what is it you guys have had
your own Wrestling Federation [__] yeah
man we've been at WWE you guys have been
in W WCW U ECW um bro before I forget
you want to hear something crazy M um my
girlfriend M three weeks ago yeah she's
like I had to dream you were on stage
with Roseanne Bar and I'm like was like
girl the [__] would I be doing on stage
with Ros bar you know what I mean and it
happened bro what it happened in the
last three weeks and I'm going to post
the text cuz he sent me that in a text
wow I'm going to post the text with the
you can see see I don't know if you can
I'm put the date maybe people just have
to believe me I guess unless it's
somewhere on the phone I don't know but
I'm going show the [__] T the date
right and then the picture how did you
end up on stage with
Roseanne um I did a podcast uh for some
comedian friends of mine J oerson did
you is it was it in Vegas yes skankfest
yes yes
bro Roseanne is a legend bro it was
insane that's sick
man I didn't get I played Seattle the
night before yeah okay no sleep at all
no sleep flew in had to meet my
girlfriend deal with all this [__] in
the morning no sleep I don't even know
what I'm going to I have no [__] idea
you know they're just like come on let
gank F you know and I thought it would
be podcast in in like a hotel or
something you know what I mean and I
didn't have no idea and they're just
lead me through and it's just getting
more lit and more lit and there's a
[__] boxing ring with two hotties
slugging it out and and there's like
tears of people hanging over the edge
and whatever and then they lead me
through and all a sudden there's like
what had to be like probably a thousand
people in this room and this huge crazy
chandeliers beautiful Vegas [__] you
know the [__] people are screaming R
Rabbid and and it's just a uh table and
chairs and they're doing a podcast you
know what I'm saying and the place is
going nuts and then they call rosan you
know what I'm saying and then they call
me up and I'm sitting next to [__]
Rosanne that'll be on YouTube if it's
not already on YouTube son yeah yeah
that's it I'm sitting next to Roseanne
and it's like how the [__] and and all
I've been eating all morning is
mushrooms nice I got some shrooms right
there I swear to you got some shrooms I
got a pound of shrooms right over
here
yeah how hard have we been looking for
shrooms last week I got a whole pound
for you if you want it ever since I went
to [__] skankfest I love listen
brother I you're my man there's like 3
lbs in that trash bag
[Music]
[__] but bro so you're shrooming
you're [__] having a time and then
Rosanne sitting next to sleep no sleep
right and I get up there everybody's up
on this stage drinking and passing
Blunts and I'm like double Captain Coke
you know what I mean and it's 2: in the
afternoon and it's just as lit and when
we do the podcast it's so lit right then
they're like we'll take it to the Green
Room so I'm going through this pack
crowd it's everybody's party it's music
[__] dancing Everybody smoke blown
weed in this fine ass establishment they
take me in the green room and it's the
exact same [__] thing just lit it's
just lit in the green room and it's dark
and there's a DJ and there's food
everywhere and I'm like What's the
[__] difference you know what I mean
I've taking mad pictures all everywhere
out there and I'm like oh Green Room
[__] yeah let's go we go relax in the
green room it's just CRA The Green Room
it's worse you know what I'm I was going
to ask you on the wrestling tip man like
you know like you said you you guys I
remember seeing you guys come out as
like like on I I want to say was it on
Raw [__] right man I took a stone
cold stunner brother you took a stunner
[__] yes I got stone cold right there
man sometimes I think I'm he's behind
your head sometimes I think I'm lying to
myself I'm like is that true Yes Man
brother you want to hear the story yes
he was
like I when we first met stone cold in
WWE he was like he sat down by me and
Joey in the arena nobody's in there yet
and he we just he's like kind of music
you like I answered him then he's like
um what kind of um do you hunt I'm like
no and he's like basically we had
nothing in common nothing in common with
Stone Cold nothing it was just like and
then so anyway like probably two month
or a month later two months whatever um
he's like all right you know how to take
a stunner and I said yes he said all
right listen I'mma come out there first
thing I'm going to do is kick you in the
stomach and give you a stunner or no he
said the first thing I'mma to do is kick
him in the stomach and and give him a
stunner I'mma pop him turn around and K
you know you got it I'm like yeah I'm
I'm I'm number two I got it you know
what I'm saying and and so he's like um
you know okay and and he's like are you
sure you got it I'm like yeah so then we
go to the gorilla position we're about
to go out there and he's like hey man
are you sure you know you know do you
know how to take a St I'm like yeah bro
I got it he goes so we go out there and
first person he kicks is me you know
what I'm saying so he did it out of
order yeah and I wasn't even expecting
it I'm like all halfway turning around
and [__] cuz I'm still thinking we got
to look like you know what I mean and
I'm just like oh you know what I mean
and I took it all shitty but I tried you
know what I mean and I'm just thinking I
want to tell did shag take it better
than you huh did he take it did Shaggy
take the stunner better than you did
Shaggy took everything better better
than me but Shaggy didn't take the
stunner oh he didn't yeah he kicked the
guy from The Headbangers okay okay gave
him a stunner at you know he was
whatever but anyway yeah it was dope
though man that's sick so you got to
hang out with Vince you got to hang out
with Stone Cold take a [__] stun I
need get to hang with v but you got to
chop it up with him for a sec meet him
say hi oh yeah yeah and and after that
every week we see him in the hallway and
say hi whatever were you guys coming out
like when you guys did the ECW thing was
this after they joined um WWE or was
this prior like Indie ECW days say it
again like when you you said you came
out at ECW right was this prior to them
joining the
conglomerate or was this when they were
still this is a real ECW so this is like
independent ECW the hot ECW where all
the stars came from Sabu Sandman you
know [__] was this in Philly has yeah at
the at the uh ECW Arena sick yeah man
did you guys meet Paul Heyman yeah I
love Paul Heyman I love him too he's my
favorite I think he's like my favorite
character I I think he's the greatest
manager ever I think he's probably the
most talented man in pro wrestling the
best mic work ever yeah did you see his
promo recently where he was crying
outside of Roman Reigns locker room no
oh my God it's art I I haven't seen
anything lately it's good is it so he's
V is gone now right yeah they sold to uh
UFC but yeah the the company so they put
a big it's it's like a a UFC and and and
WW are now owned I think
it's they have a uh TKO is the name of
the parent company um and uh I think
it's better if Triple H is running
things personally I like what Triple H
does man are so are you guys still
throwing any shows every once in a while
yeah who who's been the biggest I'm with
Billy corgan's NWA right now oh that's
sick I say for you guys cuz you guys
actually have like wrestling DVDs out
and [__] like if people ever want to go
like there's is it was it jugal World
Order uh JCW championship wrestling what
was the biggest wrestler that you guys
were able to have kind of come well we
had RI Flair at the Gathering you know
what I mean you guys brought Ric Flair
to the Gathering yeah man wow yeah and
what did he think of that [__] he was
supposed to host all night right and uh
he went out there one time he went out
there another time a [__] big ass po
almost hit him he was like thank you
very much getting [__] out of here yeah
he was out I'd be like yo before you
leave could you just give me one chop to
the chest
bro like can I take my shirt off and can
you make me pink real quick just chop
the [__] out of me pause you know what I
mean you met him no I would love to meet
him I've met i' met I've met a lot of
wrestlers I've interviewed a lot of
wrestlers but I haven't met Ric Flair
man [__] yeah man it'd be it's nice to
see him have this like Rejuvenation in
hip-hop culture like you know what I
mean like there's like uh the Griselda
guys and then obviously offset's got the
Ric Flair drip and [__] and now he's
selling weed called Ric Flair drip it's
it's pretty cool um I love it man yeah
no I love it bro it's amazing I wanted
to ask you um for for you guys cuz I had
bizar on the show maybe a year ago no
maybe seven or eight months ago and
bizar gave you guys a lot of love and
respect and flowers [__] yeah but you
guys had the beef right yeah yeah and
you guys were beefing with Eminem when
he was the biggest rapper in the world
yeah right yeah and um that had to be
interesting great publicity for you guys
a lot of new people discovered you guys
through that [__] yeah so what was that
like how serious cuz you guys are in the
same city each of you guys I'm sure are
wrapped up with some serious guys I mean
you know yeah so it wasn't like I always
tell people the problem wasn't us and M
andem it it was our camps M you know
what I'm saying run running into each
other that was the problem it was like
almost like the entourages kept that's
what I'm saying you know Throwing Fire
on the Flames our guys go all out jug
everywhere you know I mean Psychopathic
everywhere you know and um yeah man you
know that was what was stale but but um
man like like you know the thing
is what was the what was the point I can
say you could go to like I could back
then I could go to a Eminem Show right
and
um where ICP [__] would a kid get beat
up you know what I'm saying at at an
Eminem concert no and if he had ICP [__]
other way around though yes that's what
I'm saying if somebody wear Eminem Hood
that's an arena that's an arena right
we're in a small Club you right it's the
other way around don't wear a [__]
D12 hoodie to ICP show but you know
thankfully everything's cool you know
and I remember proof uh make squashing
the beef you know he seemed like he was
a peacekeeper for a lot of he was so
dope for coming over and um squashing
the beef man uh rest in peace proof he
was so dope like I was so happy to be
and honored to be included in that
because he was squashing M's beef with
names yeah he was squashing his beef
with Royce yeah he was squashing beef
with be cuz mem was going around back
then dropping crazy names you know what
I mean yeah he was and he was beefing
with a lot underground rappers like
dilated and Everlast and yeah M had some
random beefs yeah but um yeah and when
he came to the office and [__] and and
then we went bowling and drinking you
went bowling with him with D12 D12 so
with the crew and with against ICP wow
so so that was our crew yeah that's dope
it was dope more rappers should first we
were at a concert that's how people
should resolve things let's hang out and
let's [__] Bowl man
Pro started rapping because of me he
went to my high school shout out to Isam
who's in the building that's right um I
was going to
say fago is very much a thing that I
only knew about because of y'all like my
whole life I didn't know fago was a real
thing I always thought it was just your
guys's drink right didn't know it was a
thing I mean later on I I found out like
when I grew up and like you know certain
liquor stores would carry like exotic
snacks on the west coast they'd have Foo
and then we go to Detroit and any liquor
store you walk into there's like 50
flavors it's pretty crazy yeah I love I
mean did they ever give you guys a piece
of the company they don't [__] with us
that's insane let me tell you something
the only thing they ever did for us yeah
right was give us a fagel machine in our
office okay it and I'm going tell you
something else that's [__] crazy
here's why they did it right not because
you guys are oh your ICP um you know oh
dope you know it's cuz all they know is
we're probably their biggest customer
cuz you guys so all the who else buys
more Fel what like we do other than
maybe grocery Deport grocery departments
but we're right in there and they
probably put fago machines in the
grocery departments all the time too
they just think we're one of them they
don't [__] so when you guys were
launching I did they massive in Detroit
the Detroit thing we are obviously
helping these [__] massively so
when you guys are you guys are launching
all these two lers in the crowd you're
paying for those and try to talk to them
we have an attorney talk to him like
look man let's do something you know
like like just put out like a a clown
Cola or something you know a special
let's do a special cover for people that
want it [__] you know what I'm
saying I'm not asking you to put it in
grocery stores we'll buy them yeah but
let's work together so they never even
gave you guys they would even let us use
their [__] name in a in a um
isn't that ridiculous what I'm saying we
ought to throw a [__] bomb in that
place
allegedly allegedly no that is crazy cuz
I don't think I think why don't they
work with us I think the [__] you're the
you many [__] FAL I thown and sold
what the [__] over 30 years they better
work with us and suck my dick from the
back [__] from the back from the back
from the back backwards twice yeah
that's crazy so you guys were buying all
those two lers they weren't giving them
to you yeah man come on wow bro we're
getting them whatever the charging you
know I always wondered right when you
guys like would would map out your tours
you have to have
semis I was well I was I was just
curious like on tour you know you guys
map out your tours is there like a like
the venue knows like hey look man at the
end of this show you better have a
cleanup crew cuz it's going to be sticky
of course they know cuz you guys were
launching man it used to be
I remember listen to this we did back
when all we had was Detroit mhm we were
we had not popped anywhere we [__]
ran Detroit though including Toledo
which is like an hour right you know
what I mean from Detroit so um this too
radio station is doing a festival this
is like [__]
94 they're doing a festival but we're
this massive local thing right so they
put us on this festival with uh Coolio
Outcast
um uh I don't remember right now too
short Too Short Too Short you know what
I mean and we're on there and we got
F half them fans you know what I mean
aren't jug you know what I mean but
there was a lot of [__] Jugos in
there you know and it was hype but
Outcast was like what the [__] you got
fagel all over our [__] turntables
you know what I mean you know what I'm
saying they were like yo I feel him
though no we had to pay him who the [__]
are these guys throwing soda dressed
like clowns what is going on in [__]
Toledo straight up they surrounded us
I'm not going to lie so
Outcast they got mad so you guys they
walked up on us you know with a message
one dude could have said I but they sent
15 to say hey you guys got to pay for
these turntables huh you guys bought new
turntables yeah we had to buy a new
equipment for him you know what I mean
it's the right thing to do yeah of
course what's the best flavor of Foo
allegedly that's what I'm saying one guy
could have sent that said that no for
sure you know what I'm saying but what's
your favorite flavor of Foo uh and this
is assuming that they suck your dick
from the back and apologize um I like
grape grape that's pretty basic what was
the one that we had that was like blue I
don't know no no bro my favorite
favorite is um that I think is Gen IUS
is it's called firework that's the one
it's like a Bomb Pop bomb pop that
shit's fire do you know how that became
a pop fagel ran a contest think of a
flavor you know what I'm saying somebody
sent that in that's a dope [__] idea
a Bomb Pop and add some [__] SEL or
or whatever we were in Detroit and like
I remember we probably bought like nine
bottles of fago just to try we're like
bro we're never like we're this is crazy
we've never seen so many random flavor
of soda and like all the rappers are
like you got to try this one cream Peach
they got Moon Mist Red Rock and Ry you
know um they got rock and Rise Moon Mist
was good well rock rock and Rise Dr
Pepper Moon mist is is um it's m yeah
yeah you know what I'm saying no maybe
it wasn't Moon Mist I'm thinking of the
blue one yeah but the one he said um how
cool is
it to see Drake wearing y'
[__] cuz cuz there first of all I'm
don't good [__] what anybody says I
don't believe Drake wore
that having ever even heard any of our
music I think he wore that as a fashion
thing right okay I don't doubt that
because I think that's what's happening
I don't over time you know we're old
school and you know you people you know
yeah I've seen in a fashion magazine an
ICP shirt for $500 okay it was like
ripped like it old it was like a [__]
F vintage one it was a vintage one huh
no it was like fashion it was the design
of the shirt you know what say you need
to get Ace some company that's what I'm
saying that like like it's a it's a
fashion thing get what I'm saying like
Drake had the was it the Jersey huh was
Drake wearing a jersey a ring a a ring
Master Jersey which is our second album
okay come on like like the second
Joker's card you
know what the [__] is Drake doing
wearing that but but I mean listen it's
got to feel kind of cool though let me
tell you something else that makes no
sense L Co J right just did his tour is
doing his tour right he has the wall
behind them what's on the wall have you
seen it bunch of names right yeah your
name's on there my name just your name
just mine not Shaggy not ICP in the [__]
you know what I'm saying it sounds like
you're complaining
I've never met ll in my [__]
life I listen to his station all day
every day I've never heard of blip of
our [__] and we are 90s to the [__]
right core you know what I'm saying and
um I'm like why is my name on that wall
you know what I mean it makes no [__]
sense doesn't it you don't feel like
it's a it's dope to see you get some
acknowledgement of course but I think
it's like an accident or like you know
let me tell you where I think it came
from all right
what was the magazine does any Rudy was
it the New York Times and uh New York um
like that it was it was a not a magazine
a newspaper right I think it was a
newspaper well you know it could also be
his graphic guy as a jugal no I'm
telling you this newspaper came out and
it did a story the 50 greatest voices in
hip-hop and so you're you you were on
there and they he asked I was on the
list you know what I'm saying and I was
just like and at the same time
I was I did that interview for that big
newspaper yeah you get what I'm saying
um is when that tour started and I saw
my name on the wall you know that and
I'm just like what the [__] is going on
with that you know I mean they also
might they could have said ICP true you
know what I'm saying in in both true you
know but for you like I always like you
said man like when you think of jugal
historically it's the outcast of society
it's people you know a lot of people are
from broken homes a lot of you know most
of the people who I know um from a who
were jug were were just that you know
jug come from Pain and it was never it
was never the cool thing to wear it was
always like oh those are jugal you know
but to have Drake who's like the biggest
rapper on the planet rocking your guys
[__] it's almost crazy how Full Circle
that is like it's an honor you know he's
got like I don't remember but it's like
300 million followers or something on on
that do you guys see a spike in merch
sales 300 [__] million the thing is
it just looks cool though for sure like
it doesn't say I you
guys you guys really had fly another
very well possibility he might have
fashion ninjas who work for him and just
get I got this vintage Jersey yeah man
or or just whatever you know you ever
heard you know he he just yeah I just
don't think it has anything to do with
our music I what kind of of Pop was that
for you though did you guys see any like
spike in merch sales no not that I know
you know everybody's mean meaned it out
in the jugular world I bet they have and
then post Malone too shout out to post I
think post knows who you guys are huh
he's got a post post knows who shag
Shaggy meant post dope I would love to
PO meet post post is probably one of my
top three favorite artists yo can you
educate me right now oh post is amazing
you know what I'm saying it's really
hard for him to make a bad song I say
he's so [__] dope he's just such a
talented and and such a good dude it
seems super super sweet guy you know
what I mean um can you did you guys cuz
I again I'm not I I you I told you this
off the off the air I was never like a
big fan of your guys' music but I'm very
aware of you guys and your your Universe
you know did you get twisted ever squash
your guys' uh the Civil War of the the
The Jug world no [__] Twisted I got the
day I die really yeah [__] them [__]
them [__] them I ain't never been
betrayed harder in my life it was a it
was a [__] physical pain the way
those [__] betrayed me cuz you
guys did put them on like literally gave
them gave them a fan base right I gave
them the name right they didn't have
paint on they were two other rappers you
know what I mean we signed them put the
paint on
created them you know what I'm saying
they got insane Talent you know what I'm
saying but we created that you know what
I'm saying yo what up guys we got to
stop the interview to tell you about our
folks at my bookie it's winning season
right now NFL we're in the thick of it
I've been doing really good on my NFL
bets by the way plus NBA officially back
we got playoff baseball it's going crazy
especially if you like to throw down
some of that money and do a little
gambling you got to head over to my
bookie uh this was double about my
bookie it doesn't matter if your team
sucks my team the Cardinals they're
trash don't matter I'm still winning on
Sundays baby all right at my bookie all
right you can use my bookie for your
daily odd boost same game parlays and
take advantage of the crazy huge prize
pool contest plus right now my bookie
has a no strings attached that's the
important thing no strings attached cash
bonus that let you deposit and withdraw
quick that's free cash no strings
attached deposit take it out and then go
about your day or get in on some of this
NFL and NBA action baby all right just
use the promo code bootleg when you sign
up go to mybookie.ag use the promo code
bootleg on your first deposit and you'll
receive up to $200 in cash what are we
talking about no strings attached what
my bookie use the promo code bootleg all
right maybe you want to gamble on some
NFL maybe you want to get in on some of
this early NBA action maybe you want to
get in on some of this playoff baseball
it's really on you use the promo code
bootleg and receive up to $200 in cash
that's right try my bookie right now use
that promo code bootleg and you can grab
um how about this man there's some crazy
odds going on and I like this one cuz
what you can do is you can throw down on
a potential Super Bowl front runner and
uh plus
38,000 on the Eagles and Chiefs on the
Super Bowl plus 38 ,000 if you put
$100 you win
$38,000 you're not going to get those
odds anywhere mybookie.ag use the promo
code bootleg right now bet anything
anytime anywhere only with my bookie
plus we got to give a big shout out to
our family at King palom man we love
King pal over here on the bootle C
podcast this is what's great about King
pom first of all it's all about that
organic no tobacco leaf this thing right
here here's a boy look at that that's
just a leaf right there King pong they
got everything you need man they got
these cones with the squeeze and pop
tpin in them the flavors this right here
is the uh the dragon fruit we got the
grape HD the watermelon wav so many
flavors what's dope about King pal if
you're in whatever City you're in you
could find King pal at your local smoke
shop your local 7-Eleven all right I'm
telling you King pom you're not going to
ever ever experience a more cleaner more
natural more just great way to smoke
what you're smoking all right you stuff
one of these boys up with some flour uh
and and you just you're Off to the Races
I'm telling you you hit the tip you get
hit with that flavor and it's man it's
nothing like it the squeeze and pop on
King pom is insane all right and they
got all size cones all right so go to
King pom man organic tobacc free leaves
of all sizes like this is a this is a
this is look look we're talking about
all sizes here what are we talking about
what are we talking about here boys all
right go to King pom.com right now you
can order whatever you want man they got
accessories they got trays they got
Grinders they got ashtrays they got damn
all kind of flavors of their leaves
everything 50% off when you use the
promo code bootleg that's 50% off order
whatever you want at King pom.com let's
get back to the interview like it was it
was what was the Betrayal the fact that
they you know they they were dropping
end bombs everywhere in um in the Raps
like you know what I mean and we're like
what the [__] are y'all doing you know
what I mean we had to
[__] hone them in you know what I'm
saying cuz they're talented as [__] they
were talented as [__] you know we had to
hone them in and they're just dumb and
and wild style you know but we [__]
showed them how to do is showed them out
of market showed them all that [__] you
know what I'm saying and and bring them
on tour the first time we ever built
ourselves up to go on a national tour
and a bus they were in the [__]
opening you know what I'm saying we just
gave them love I at first The Jug The
Jug were like when they came out two guy
two other guys in clown Paint The Jug
were
like [__] you you know what I'm
saying you know what I'm saying and it
took us years you know what I mean for
them to accept them yeah man we were
like these are our boys we're putting
them out Psychopathic you know what I
mean and still people couldn't
understand the idea of jugal being
something different than ICP right they
didn't want to bring you guys had like
and it was a fat guy and a skinny guy
just like me you know me it's was like
what the [__] well and then a lot of
your guys' artists ended up with face
paint Blaze your dad homie and anybody
killer that's what I'm saying we we did
our label like a wrestling yeah brother
we created characters we were like all
right Blaze what what does Blaze do you
know Blaze is from back in the day with
when they wore the clock you know what
I'm saying and Raiders [__] and
everything and he got killed
and now he's supposed to be current
rapping that old [__] that was our idea
back then you know what I'm saying and
um and then uh anybody kill up right he
was native right yeah I was like what do
you uh what's your uh ha what I what
what is your ethnicity or whatever and
he was like I'm native and I'm like rep
that because yo the natives love y'all I
told I told him rep that yeah you know
what I'm saying in all your [__] you
know and and we just helped these
[__] and signed them and BR
them on tour I'm paying all these ninjas
to open for us in front of our own Crow
right right right right I'm [__]
paying these [__] all my life
it was like 10 years 15 years I think 16
years I I did that wit Twisted you know
what I'm saying paying them you know so
was the Betrayal the fact that they left
the label you know what the problem was
bro when they got bigger in the Jugo
world and jug loved them yeah because
they they became really big right IP
come to town and draw 2500 or something
on on a good night
right have them on the tour we do the
same thing same tickets exactly but
we're paying them all this money you
know it was that like that forever MH
that but we we loved them right you know
what I'm saying then there was a group
called um Axe Murder boys right and um
they won a contest we like had a contest
and [__] to see who were going to sign
you know they won a contest Twisted was
like [__] them you know what I mean they
won the contest they were like they feel
why they they won a contest they don't
deserve to be here [__] them they would
even Twisted wouldn't even let them come
in the studio oh wow right so the the uh
one guy in in X murder boy young Wicked
he was like um he had like a hatred for
Twisted after that you know so years
later when Twisted started their own
label and all that you know what I mean
they signed him huh did they sign that
guy okay no the guy at the I remember at
the Gathering at the Young Wicked show
he's like all I got to say is
psychopathic for life [__] that other
noise everybody knew exactly what he was
talking about you know the whole crowd
and [__] and and um then
um so when when uh we got betrayed that
[__] they that was when that
dude that dude Young Wicked he was my he
was my uh Protege prot yeah he was my
producer I'm putting them on yeah I love
that kid so much I was
like it's my goal I'm sry let me take a
drink do your
thing I said I never said this for
anybody I said it's my goal to see you
and your family in living in a paid off
house in Detroit all right with
significant money in the bank that's my
goal right that's what we were working
toward for him because he had his two
kids out there and his girl was pregnant
again you know what I'm saying and that
was his dream to move them here you know
what I'm saying and he wanted to live in
Detroit you know what I'm saying that
[__] got my brother's daughter
pregnant you know what I'm saying and
betrayed the [__] hell out of
all of us your brother's daughter yeah
how old was she she was uh of Asia she
was up age okay but still that's crazy
bro heed it he denied it he denied it
well he got my brother told me man it
was no what happened was my brother's
daughter told my
brother hey I've been messing around
with uh young Wicked and my brother was
like what and so my brother didn't tell
none of us cuz at the time he's got a
pregnant girl too or he has a he's got
family I'm saying that he worships and
puts his [__] on in front of us you know
so my brother's own daughter tells him
hey I've been with young Wicked you know
so my brother pulls that [__] in
in the room in the office you know what
I mean just him and he's
like stay the [__] away from my daughter
you know what I'm saying she ain't your
local peace my brothers a d at
Psychopathic you know what I'm saying
there's four of us me my brother Joey
and Billy my brother is a Don and this
[__] and my brother said I'm not
going to tell anybody what you did you
know what I'm saying man not going to
tell
anybody stay the [__] away from my
daughter you know what I'm saying right
that's crazy so a month later my
brother's daughter tells him she's still
seeing him you know what I'm saying oh
so my brother had to tell us and it was
like you know so listen all that
happened right when Twisted in our us
fell out when you guys had your yeah
right and [__] they signed them the
next like the the day Rob let us know
you guys dropped him there was a picture
the next day him with them like this it
was insane they hated each other for
years yeah they didn't even want him in
the studio until they had something in
common and that was [__] y [__] yeah
on us and it was insane bro these were
my my gu my prot like you said yeah
anyway I [__] all that you know yeah
[__] them all man [__] all that [__]
anybody killer all of them [__]
Blaze all them [__] can [__]
the [__] off I hate them so it's safe to
say there'll never be another dark I
never think about them I don't I don't I
didn't see I see I'm like I said like
I'm I'm aware of you and twisted issues
I didn't know you had issue everybody
else but you you definitely gave a lot
of people a lot of careers and and the
one thing is is but you know what man if
jug coming rocking that [__] is
something I don't give a [__] but I was
going to say the one thing is is you
guys have you know I think some people
um don't understand like if you guys
Embrace an artist not even necessarily
somebody who signed to
you you're if you let them into your
world those fans are instant instant if
now we we put so many people on they're
going to buy tickets they're going to
buy the shirts and they're going to
support you and they're like the most
dedicated fans there are in music so
well man it's crazy but um it's no
different than than it is on a on a
massive uh Glo Global [__] level like
Jay and everybody right you know what
I'm saying it's just kind a smaller
thing you know but it's definitely true
if we if we put out an artist and put
them on tour and we give him the stamp
jugal unless that [__] is
something they reject right you know
what I'm saying which which you know um
but that [__] is granted and you're
going to be um making money you're going
to be able to tour you know small clubs
and [__] like we were talking about like
you know hey how cool is it speaking of
that you guys had jelly roll on tour
with you we got IGI Ma you know who that
is I I don't bro well I was going to say
before you tell me how cool is it to see
jelly become a a country [__]
Superstar and what was it like three or
four years ago he was on your guys' tour
yeah it's pretty wild it is it's like
kind of cool to just see like
everybody's getting their just do you
know [__] yeah man the way that he can
be a rapper and a country yeah yeah I
think everybody needs to get off his
dick though like like um people doing
his [__]
that whole sound
now the whole thing of being in the
studio playing the song you know and I
now everybody want to do that get off
his dick you're right about that there's
a lot of [__] you got 900 jelly rolls
all sudden there's a lot of people who
see what he's doing and they're like hey
maybe we should try to new country off
dick exactly you sound pathetic you know
what I'm saying you sound [__] um yeah
you want to walk him out there um just
do a wide shot I was going to say you do
you do have a new album that you're
toring right now with Isam and uh Ouija
ma Ouija ma yeah three-headed monster
it's like a side project you know what I
mean that I'm doing with them and uh
Shaggy just got off tour so you guys are
doing your solo [__] right now and then
this side project so tell me about the
three-headed monster well Ouija is an
artist that we that we uh signed
and you know it's just weird the way
[__] evolution is because after
twisted and all
that we signed Ouija and um and we
signed some other guys you know what I
mean we kind of put out after all the
many we tried rebuild the label for a
minute but we
Luigi is
um a [__] machine a Workhorse
you know what I'm saying like he drops a
video every I mean a goodlook
professional video like literally every
month when he's not torn you know what I
mean he's got like another goodlook
video and he's pumping it hard he's
touring all the time like we just did a
month we're on tour right now right yeah
and and and uh right when I go home he
starts his next 6 week tour you know
what I'm saying right he grinds like
that and his merchandise ideas are dope
like he Incorporated all this Asian [__]
into his name and [__] just like just
weird like a uh Japanese writing on on
the Jersey and [__] it just looks dope
you know what I mean like he comes up
with things I don't see anybody doing
and suddenly you see everybody the
jugglers all doing it you know another
another dude is uh Shaggy the Airhead
he's a [__] uh DJ
right I start in his Beats he's got the
tag Shaggy the Airhead you know like
that right so he makes Beats too right
yeah yeah and um I we use his Beats in
our music for now like like last five
years right he also is a [__] um uh
artist and a clothing guy right and his
clothes are [__] outr right I believe
that dude's out selling our [__] in the
Jugo World wow because the everywhere I
go when I rock this [__] people are like
dope outfit you know what I mean he's
going to be a monster I believe that's
dope like I think he's going to outgrow
like his [__] could pop in hip-hop that
fashion it's that [__] dope looking
his his merch are you and Shaggy ever
going to hang it up and and and retire
cuz I feel I feel like I feel like
passion has to be the driving force for
anybody doing music right is there like
like I mean you guys still love it
obviously yeah could you see yourself
getting to a point where you're like
this is the final ICP album no there's
seven there's uh six six more to make
you know what I mean in our in our
uh hopefully Legacy you know what I'm
saying well cuz all the albums are kind
of like connected right huh yeah yeah
there's the first six Joker CS came out
you know it's just a black cover with a
clown face on it you know and then uh
the second now we're in the second deck
is five you know it's six there's going
to be six six five right and that
five is
because like let me explain it like this
after the first six it offers the end
like the six Joker's card was Heaven or
Hell right that's the sixth Joker's card
in the second deck
you know the next album that's what
everybody's waiting to see what it's
going to be you know what I mean in the
juggle world you guys already got all
this planned out yeah but the five the
last five you know what I mean um it
doesn't have a six Jokers card because
we die for real get what I'm saying it's
supposed to show you how to inside it's
supposed to show you how to be a better
person make you and and um it also helps
you vent like the people were killing in
the music are pedophiles and racists and
[__] like that you know and it's like um
people get therapy from that [__] you
know what I mean and uh uh wife beaters
and [__] you know abuse child abusers
they come from that [__] or whatever
they have that problem you know what I'm
saying their wife their wife or husband
does beat them you get what I'm saying
in the venting you know and the music's
there for us creating these illusions of
going in there and killing them with
[__] axes and chainsaws the way we
describe it and everything it's it's um
it's it's fantasy right you know what
I'm saying yeah you guys are definitely
everybody's always saying keep it real
keep it real we're all in a real world
all the [__] time you know what I'm
saying I don't want the music why can't
the music do something else once in a
while why is that somewhere else yeah
there's nothing wrong with that you know
what I mean n for sure um give me let me
ask you another question you you
introduced us as hip-hop Legends how the
[__] if we're hip-hop Legends how the
[__] is Source magazine never even made
a blip mention of our name I just think
that you guys are uh you guys are the
underground for real I feel like for
whatever reason commercial hip-hop
Publications never embraced you guys and
I think um that's what I was kind of
going to get to is I think that there
was a point in time like you said you
guys would come out everybody flip you
guys off and it was cool to hate you
guys right what do you think is the
biggest misconception though about cuz I
feel like there's a stereotype about
jugal right what do you think is the
biggest misconception about
jugal oh
um you know that that if you I guess
today I'm I like where jug sit in pop
culture yeah you know what I mean I see
jokes and [__] on sitcoms and TV you
know people know what they are yeah you
you know jug my my man are the very
reason
were
legit for sure you know what I mean they
change your guys' life I mean they you
know yeah people people um have such a
big opinion about these jugal and it
it's people right what has been the
craziest it's dentists [__]
mechanics like I'll meet people random
places and and it's crazy to like oh you
have you got a hatch man tattoo on your
leg oh like you know like who what has
been the most like like random person
who has an occupation like a crazy job
that happens to be a Juggle though like
is it a cop is it a FBI agent is it a
dentist is it you know MH I I've seen
cops all the time you know what I mean
um one time me and Joy were standing out
we used to have a TV show on The Fuse
Network and we're standing out in New
York doing that in the in the [__]
cop car came pulling up right right on
us you know the guy get S he like dude
let me get an autograph I love you guys
you know he's got the Brooklyn accent
you know that was dope but but um damn
that's a good question because I say
this like when I when I when I explain
to people who you who you guys are I say
there there's they have fans I said
there's [__] people who you would not
even guess with their faces or their
logo tattooed on them right now you know
I mean yeah the the um the um I I me you
know I had like heart problems right and
um a heart surgeon um contacted me and
he's like um brother I would love to sit
you down and talk man I um I I'm a
doctor you know what I mean and I grew
up on your [__] I love you you know what
I mean he's a [__] heart suron you
know what I mean and he's like um and
I'm like you're my new doctor ninja you
know what I mean he he because I don't
even like my [__] doctor you know but
I I was like you're my new doctor not
that I have a relationship I ain't seen
my any doctor in a year you get what I'm
saying but I'm like anything goes wrong
you're my doctor you know what I mean
and um [__] yeah and I was I'm thinking
I'm have to fly to see him and I'm like
where you at where you in out and he's
like Rochester and I was like oh that's
like I'm think of Rochester New York
he's like no Rochester Michigan I'm like
what drive to you you're local you know
what I mean I was like [__] yeah dog
that's a [__] you know like right there
you know what I mean that's super dope
man yeah but I
Ferris oh Ferris is an attorney yeah a
homie you know what I mean that's the
guy we sued the uh FBI with wow he he is
a Jugo that recognized me at the mall
and he's like I'm an attorney I'm at the
mall with my girl and I was like [__]
yeah you know what I mean you're my
attorney now he's a jugler he's like I
grew up on [__] I know everything and
I'm like word so the next Big Show's uh
Halloween right
um yeah and then what what month do you
guys usually do the Gathering is it
summertime uh in August August yeah it's
hot as [__] it's hot yeah usually but
it's been pretty good last couple years
nice man it was hot as [__] you guys do
it like on private land too I heard
right which makes it you know a lot more
fun I'm sure yeah you know and um we do
the most outrageous [__] bro I've heard
you know listen to this uh
we got this thing it's like a a hay ride
we charge like 300 bucks M right it's a
it's a hay ride and you get a a CD
single of a song right a rare song on uh
never heard before song right and um we
take you through across the way from the
Gathering into the woods right and we do
this hunt for
bigfoot what right and you guys are
there with them yeah me and Joy are sit
sitting up on a c a hay Barrel things
looking at the crowd there's probably
like 60 people on this hay ride yeah you
know what I mean and we do three a night
we do them all [__] night but they're
the [__] funnest [__] of my life and
I'm telling you right now I have no
problem doing that I wish I could do
that every night in Vegas or something
for but bro we make it so [__] fun
like like suddenly you'll see a big foot
we got like you know suddenly we do you
know have big out there and then um a
shootout between hunters and a Bigfoot
you know and there's a you know it's
just super funny but anyway we do a
whole thing it's like a haunted hay Rod
sort of you know but it's like really
funny cuz me and Joey are doing live
commentary but this last year we did
bigfoots and alien thing MH so my
brother's like we need to do aliens this
year and I'm like how the [__] we can do
that on the uh on the uh hay ride and he
was like watch and man he made that
[__] is so funny and dope that's
dope it was so [__] amazing like
there's a turned over car over here
smoking and there's a guy laying there
something lifted my car up and flammed
it on the ground you know and he's like
I need help so we we pull him on the
thing and then um me and Joy are just
cracking on him as you
know and so um uh then then we turned
the corner and [__] and my brother had
like lights in in the [__] woods and
[__] and um sound
effects the most corny looking UFO the
[__] was amazing bro well listen man um
the threed monster albums out right huh
the three-headed monster album is out
yeah we got two albums out two albums
tours happening how many more dates
left um just like four four tour is
almost over yeah um you guys man I just
listen like I said I got to I respect
y'all for you know just man you guys
built an Empire over the last 30 years
and uh done it independently done it
your way so salute man thank you man I
think a lot of a lot of people don't
even understand that you you guys laid
the the blueprint down for a lot of
artists that are following it to this
day but they don't even know it yeah man
yeah well you know we're just doing it
like like the Ghetto Boys did you know
like uh James Smith did you know what I
mean and we we're we're we're um yeah
doing it following the way e did it you
know what I mean and uh and and text
doing it and and it's C you don't really
[__] need a label no more yeah why
the [__] do you need a label you know
what I mean you can post your own [__]
you can make your own video and post
that on YouTube like what the [__] else
is a label you know what I mean CDs
don't even exist no more there's no
actual product anymore there's nothing
to store there's nothing to ship you
know what I'm saying like well I mean
you guys have a great like you guys have
[__] to sell like you said it's still
important for you to sell physical CDs
and yeah but like you you know if I was
a young artist and they were like um if
a young artist asked me for advice I'd
be like [__] YouTube and record label
yoube and stay Indie yeah man 100% yo um
you were say saying this off the air a
bit but you um for people who don't know
this is pretty [__] hilarious but uh
you know there is a a young rapper Who's
on who was on the freshman cover baby
Tron yeah and uh his dad was signed to
you guys yeah well yeah I didn't see
here I didn't know anything about baby
Tron right okay I was doing a um I was
doing um what's it called in La
um no jumper no jumper yeah and um
afterward he's like hey yo um do you
mind sticking around and I was like why
he's like cuz I we got a a a upcoming
rapper Who's you know really popping off
really hard you know and getting you
guys in the picture would be legendary
you know so I was I was like cool you
know cuz we're both from Detroit or
whatever you know so yeah he shows up
and we're going to take the picture you
know what I mean and he's and we're
taking a picture and he's like I grew up
at your house
dog and I was just like hey RI you know
like say it again like what' you say and
he's like I grew up at your house you
know my dad is sadistic you know and I
was
like bro this kid is my son's friend
like they they used he's been coming to
my house for years watching wrestling
pay-per-views crazy you know what I mean
and it's just I like what you know what
I mean he's just killing it you know
yeah I was like well good for you man
that's a [__] brother no that shit's
sick man let's do a [__] song yeah do
definitely do a song yeah baby try you
owe me for all them [__] barbecues
all that food all the I was I was
putting the bill on the pay-per-view get
on that give me a hot
16 there it is man look violent Jay
appreciate you pulling up bro hell yeah
I appreciate you my man for
real fire good [__] man what's going on
man I want to shout out to our family a
hardan for presenting to you another
interview all right there's another
interview coming tomorrow and the next
day and the next day shout out to harden
though if you're in Las Vegas man the
number one dispensary in the world there
are family there are brothers there are
[__] dogs over there man we love them
they always are taking care of us and
they'll take care of you if you go to
harden in Vegas let's say you're Landing
in Vegas you're gonna go watch the
Raiders you're gonna go watch a Vegas
show whatever get in that taxi tell them
straight up take me to harden when you
get to harden they gon get you hooked up
with the craziest uh just variety and
selection of Premium cannabis on the
planet and if you tell them you heard
about us on the on on the bootleg cev
show you say hey uh hardine I heard
about y'all on the bootleg C podcast
they're gonna take care of y'all all
right so go follow him Harden Las Vegas
on all social media and check them out
Hardin Las vegas.com what's up Harden